Allen came to the Welsh Secretary has
quit look fit what not so as as well
secretary now what happened was last
night allegations emerged by the BBC
that the Welsh Secretary had been
informed that one of his former aides
had effectively acted in a way that
bring down a rape trial and one of the
victims was reported to be calling on
mr. Kent to quit notably Lal last night
and all this morning Danning Street did
not seek and offer opportunities to
defend mr. Kane's basically silent from
there and in the last few seconds we've
got the letter from Allen Kent to the
prime minister I will read it for the
first time to you here he says first of
all this is from Boris Johnson to Alan
Kay and saying thank you for your letter
resigning as Secretary of State to Wales
I'm pleased to hear that you will
cooperate fully with the Cabinet Office
during this process so that implies that
there is a some kind of investigation
that is going on I'm extremely grateful
for all your work I'd like to put on
record all of your your work as
secretary of state and you can be proud
of your record now he's worth saying
that Alan Kane's one of the law I think
the last cabinet minister to be
appointed by David Cameron but today the
first official day of the campaign to be
hit with a resignation from his cabinet
he's hardly the backdrop that he was but
let's be clear about this mr. Kenzie's
is he standing still as a candidate in
this election we are we are I'm aware
that he's standing down as well
secretary we are waiting to find out
whether he's standing in this election
so we will find out